you know I'm notorious for my love of
gray characters and one of the greatest
characters and entire story Westeros is
daemon targaryen the rogue Prince we we
took one of the sidebars made a separate
story out of it the rogue Prince daemon
is the younger brother of King Viserys
the first for a time he was the heir to
the throne
when Viserys had no children and then
Viserys started having children and he
stopped being the heir to the throne
he's notorious bad boy a rogue in every
sense of the word he was a rival for the
Sarah's sister and his own niece
rhaenyra and then later he became the
husband of her Neera he switched his
side several times you never know what
side he's going to come down on he's a
very colorful and unpredictable
character and I think he has to rank up
there is my favorite but the the book is
full of what I hope are interesting
characters
Lari on the black grid he is the oldest
and largest of the Targaryen dragons
he's the only one born in valaria when
the Targaryen fled valaria before the
doom
they brought I believe I say five
dragons with them one by one those
dragons died on Dragonstone only
balerion survived past a conquest and to
be the the leading and most powerful
dragon of the age so he's gigantic and
old and difficult to master or tame he
was a God's dragon Aegon the dragon
Aegon the conquerer the founder of the
whole Targaryen dynasty and after a gods
death
various other riders a road or attempted
to ride balerion some more happily than
others but he is certainly a legend
among the the Dragons of of the
Targaryen dynasty he was the Lord of
Dragonstone one of a succession after
the after the Targaryen is fled valaria
and settled on Dragonstone in advance of
the doom a number of them came and went
mostly their eyes still gazed east
toward Essos but as the years pass and
son succeeded father and brother
succeeded brother they began to take
more interest in the affairs of Westeros
and Aegon finally decided to take over
Westeros and unify the Seven Kingdoms
that existed at a time under a single
rule there is a lot of speculation that
in some sense he saw what was coming
300 years later and wanted to unify the
Seven Kingdoms to be better prepared for
the threat that he eventually saw coming
from the north
the threat that we're dealing with in a
Song of Ice and Fire
yes Joe Harris the conciliator the old
king was the longest-reigning of the
Targaryen monarchs he took the crown
when he was 14 years old and held it I
believe for 55 years and Alison was his
sister and his wife theirs was a great
romance if you'll accept that an
incestuous relationship can be a great
romance and they were for most of their
reigns they were they were partners they
worked together I mean Joe Harris ruled
but Alison had an immense amount of
influence over him and on a number of
occasions he took her advice or passed
laws that that she urged
yeah thing about Daenerys of course is
she lives in a time when the dragons
have been gone for hundreds of years no
one has seen the living dragons since
the events chronicled in fire and blood
so this is a book that Daenerys actually
might benefit from reading but she has
no access to archmaester guild Dean's
crumbling manuscripts so she's operating
on her own there and maybe she
understood a few things more about
dragons her own history and in Essos
would have gone a little differently but
we shall see fans all have to make up
their own mind about that
[Music]